[Applause]
we talked about netflix yes
do you immediately want to talk about
why hbo is better okay it's not that i
like hbo better they just are better
they are better they're better at
scripted and it's not even a [ __ ]
it's not even close and not only they're
better at making the scripted shows
they're better at getting people to
watch the scripted shows okay okay this
weekend
[ __ ] uh
sex in the city comes out with their
older sex and i did not even know it
came out nobody knew it was coming out
yeah there was no interest no no girls
didn't give a [ __ ] about it they're like
i don't need to watch these girls
anymore i saw them go to [ __ ] dubai
or whatever like that and walk around
with masks all day long i don't need to
see this [ __ ] again and the one
character that everybody knew about was
gone the most entertaining character
maybe not the one you love the most
probably it's carrie or each one of
these girls has their own thing but
undeniably the funniest most
entertaining one the one that got [ __ ]
all the time great tits for age is off
the ship right yeah so you're like okay
why the hell would i watch this [ __ ] if
now they're old i don't care about their
lives the one that was the funniest and
the most entertaining is no longer there
like what is the point like just a bunch
of madonnas just [ __ ] in their 60s
complaining yeah get that [ __ ] over with
bro okay
within a [ __ ] day every girl is
watching this thing they're locked in
and obsessed within a [ __ ] day what
did they do they killed off one of the
main characters they killed off carrie's
[ __ ] love interest for the whole
regular show
big you know that show the guy big i
know of him uh christopher noth yeah i
think he's a character they killed that
[ __ ] off and this is how you
know this [ __ ] has a big [ __ ] uh
reaction right um yeah i was talking
about how this wasn't as big a reaction
as just in my girl's life i'll stand on
this okay ready um
big dies after
using a peloton he is a heart attack
mr
dies after using a peloton peloton stock
dips 11
yep that's [ __ ] crazy 11
you might have also contributed to that
that's bitcoin [ __ ] it's like when
bitcoin dips five percent people were
like oh [ __ ] is bitcoin on it down yeah
ten percent yeah
they saw that they saw the video of you
falling off and they were like yeah yeah
that contributed to two i started this
at least i started this
the reason hbo is great is because i'm
great
it's okay i'm complimenting me yeah
we understand martial as mr big that was
mr big nose
this is what it is
okay so
listen so the [ __ ] effect of this is
crazy right to kill off a main character
and the love interests of this woman
actually it's really the smartest thing
because in order for us to like this
show she can't be happy that's game of
thrones you gotta have steaks
opening season you're like the two
coolest guys are dead
what happened and they keep on killing
the [ __ ] you love if you love
them too much that [ __ ] are
gonna die they've been married because
they got married in a movie i believe
yeah first or second i don't know yeah
but they were married 10 11 years that's
not fun who wants to see that show
there's no stakes there oh so we got to
be single we need to follow carrie's
journey which is in podcasting now the
takeover
[ __ ] [ __ ] we do jesus
so it's like in order to recreate that
world and in order to follow this woman
through that world trying to find out
what her life is going to be what love
is going to be you need to remove the
love yeah right if you already got a man
you're happy you're in a nice house then
you're flying a [ __ ] abu dhabi yeah
right it's like they literally had
nothing else to do so they flew them to
[ __ ] abu dhabi right i thought it was
absolutely brilliant everybody talking
about main character dies one of the
main character dies man love interest
dies now all of a sudden my girl's
locked in watching and then the writing
is funny i'm watching the show and i'm
like this is funny i remember thinking
it was funny before the story lines get
you in i'm like you [ __ ] did it hbo
[ __ ] does it every single time mayor
of east town right yeah mayor of east
town comes down
the [ __ ] finale
all of a sudden the stream goes down
i didn't start watching this show until
after the finale when the stream went
down
the stream going down causes national
news right everybody going what the [ __ ]
you mean in the street it's trending on
twitter the mayor of east town is
trending why are people so upset they
can't watch the show it must be a good
show yeah the show's [ __ ] great i go
i watch it yeah white lotus the undoing
it's like non-stop they keep coming with
banger after banger scripted show can
y'all name a scripted show that netflix
has put out in the last year that people
are obsessed with scripted kevin
hardship squid game squid game
it was fire when it first started that
fell off i gave up i think squid game is
massive yeah that's the biggest house
and then true story true story true
story is is mid i think it's mid it's
but you uh it's highly what they got
shows what's that one marco's fade or
something
narcos i think people stop watching
narcos you you was big in terms of just
eyeballs yeah you is big in terms of
eyeballs you're you're also talking
critical acclaim i think
like undoing was very well received
critically and people watched it uh
mayor of east town same but like what's
that [ __ ] show with entourage that
has the entourage guy in it vinnie click
bait or some [ __ ] like that oh yes that
was people it wasn't a good show
buddy people watching more people
watching people watched it you think
those are limited series easier to get
superstar creators and and talents right
here
they don't have their game of thrones
yet they don't have their sopranos they
don't have their witcher they don't have
the wire nobody watching the witcher
like they got all these shows like
squid game was a breakout show i mean
like it had that like tiger king effect
right it was like mainstream people are
locked in if you didn't watch it you had
the fomo right there's this there's this
uh i think we've talked about it on a
podcast before but like there's a
trajectory with content and it's not
just with a show it could be with a
movie it could be with a tour it could
be anything there's a director where
it's like you're in on this thing early
all of a sudden you're in on this thing
and sharing with people and then it hits
a critical mass where if you haven't
watched it you feel weird yeah you're
the outsider the only show
that
that happened with that i can remember
in recent uh past with netflix is squid
game a little bit of things with true
story a little bit of truth andrew
richardson bridgeton i was just about
right
which is huge everybody was talking
about that a few years ago
but yes they were talking about hazards
tons of misses that's what i'm saying
hbo has thousands which was a dud john's
and mrs
but you're also talking netflix has
local market producers everything they
have hundreds of more
executives trying to find the
development i'm just comparing budgets
here like the budget for hbo and the
budget for now you have to bring that
point in because netflix can throw money
because they can't miss like it was
remember when amc back in the day went
on that string of non-stop
bangers
like amc's
breaking bad bang bang and then walking
dead mad men breaking bad walking dead
there was another one that came out on
amc as well that people were [ __ ]
with like i think
or something like that was fx fx but
like it was just after another and
you're like holy [ __ ] does this channel
actually the truth and they made it
relevant yeah yeah it's relatively their
budget that's a crazy run unbelievable
for hbo yeah that makes sense that's why
i'm saying they're so great is it they
will spend 30 million dollars on a
[ __ ] pilot for a game of thrones
prequel not the one that's coming out
but another one and if it's not good
scrap it yeah like 30 million dollars in
the air because they know
they're like this isn't it
you know what it's kind of like i
remember hearing walmart and target
started off as competitors and then
walmart was so good at being cheaper
that target was like we can't do what
they can do we can't compete with cheap
[ __ ] so let's just make stuff that's
nicer than what walmart makes and charge
more that's like trader joe's too trader
joe's might have done that it's like
they don't have any of the selection but
all their [ __ ] slaps is bangers
yeah yeah and trader joe's is cheap but
target was like look we're gonna be more
selective of what we have and i think
that might be what hbo is doing like
look we're not netflix can just throw
money at everything and have
options for every single human being on
earth they have the budget we don't we
have to be more selective with ours and
make it more appealing like especially
critically and and i just have to say
like the way that that hbo does their
marketing i don't know if they're aware
of it or not but the way that they do
their marketing is just [ __ ] genius
like
they're able to like stir up controversy
around their shows which creates that
fomo effect where you're like why is
everybody upset like right now the
there's this whole thing going on with
succession i don't watch succession i
don't care about like building their
[ __ ] is that hbo also but like
everybody's talking about that oh yeah
it's a cultural moment yeah and like
there was something with one of the
characters jeremy strong
was being criticized and aaron sorkin
felt like he had to do a public apology
but he
doesn't have social media so he put it
on jessica chastain social media it's
just like
just that type of conversation piece
swirling around a show you're like what
the [ __ ] is happening in this show
netflix doesn't seem to have that
apparatus where they can get all this
controversy churning like they have
tons of data and they can push stuff to
you algorithmically but they're not
creating the conversation
outside of it like dude mr beast doing
the squid game thing yeah that's what
you need now you're not gonna get that
every time but like how can you get the
conversation churning outside yeah
that's what a comedy special does yeah
that's dave chappelle
drove people to netflix because of the
controversy yeah i feel like netflix
strategies like just put all the budget
into just making content yeah buy
everything yeah [ __ ] even when we did
the thing they were like yeah we don't
do billboards like what we what we do is
just use the algorithm to push it to the
people that are going to see it yeah
right and it's like okay but like [ __ ] a
billboard let's use some money to
you know create some drama yeah like
let's create some conversation around
the piece that's going to drive people
to the piece and i think that's what
[ __ ] hbo does when when they put out
the peloton ad i believe wholeheartedly
that this was part of the deal yeah can
you explain that okay so basically
peloton stock drops 10 or 11 after uh
the mr big dies
going on the peloton yeah right gets a
heart attack
i think
personally
okay so then an advertisement comes out
very little
a peloton ad there with christopher noth
being healthy i guess we could play it
yeah you want to check it out yeah right
now
[Music]
if you're listening to new beginnings
to new beginnings
you look great i feel great
should we take another ride
life's too short not to
[Music]
and just like that the world was
reminded that regular cycling stimulates
and improves your heart lungs and
circulation reducing your risk of
cardiovascular diseases cycling
strengthens your heart muscles lowers
resting pulse and reduces blood fat
levels he's alive
he's alive
ryan reynolds
does the voice over does the voice over
it's mr big and an asian chick or a
mexican girl on that show she might be
an instructor for peloton right oh she's
a famous peloton instructor
she was the one i think he was watching
in the show okay oh
hilarious okay extremely well
coordinated and orchestrated well this
is extremely quickly you know what's
crazy that's crazy
let me just say so i think
this is another hbo move yeah i think if
hbo is going to make it look like you
get [ __ ] heart attacks going on
pelotons to a key demographic that uses
[ __ ] peloton there's a leverage point
it is like literally who are the people
who use peloton [ __ ] people who watch
sex in the city yeah yeah it's sex in
the city people girls who watch sex in
the city and maybe their boyfriends like
me and some comedians some comedians get
stuck under them yeah trying to look
good for their wedding that's it that
might be part of the demo it's a
possibility i went back on it i'm a
[ __ ] yeah i saw you okay listen i'm
like big
did you run extra hard to stomp it yeah
i did i almost fell filming that video
100 percent i was like no no audition
but my point is
i bet you they reach out to peloton
they're like listen we're gonna do this
it's going to cause a controversy i
don't know what's going to happen but
why don't you have something really fun
cooked up to go along with it they must
have notified the brand i don't even
know if you can use a brand without
their products here's a crazy thing i'll
i have to potentially push back what
peloton was already working with ryan
reynolds uh creative agency he's got a
marketing firm
right and they
apparently cooked this up they were
already working with them and this was
like a 48 hour we got to do something
fix because
otherwise i don't think peloton would
risk having that no one would approve
the risk that you could drop that much
with uh your stock price for hbo to even
mention peloton in their show they got
the approval to use it but someone from
peloton may not have read the script
yeah right no i think they got this yeah
right and they said yeah we'll we'll do
it but we're going to have something
ready we're going to cast it out
even helped him out here we're going to
do this [ __ ] here we'll help you we'll
help you create an ad
you know what i mean oh yeah and they
might not even help them create the ad
they just told them more or less what's
going to happen
and again you're not going to give away
the script more or less what's going to
happen hey there's going to be some some
tragedy after the use of the peloton
whatever like that just want to let you
guys know you guys do what you want to
do okay
and
getting the christopher nov character to
go film that like that's even a little
bit peculiar yeah right like you're
undermining the show now christopher nov
is aware that his character is dead not
he is dead yeah but he's basically going
i didn't really die i'm out here and i'm
with the instructor and i just wanted to
leave carrie yeah you're kind of
undermining the plot of the show so i
think there has to be some sort of
communication between both of them hey
you're gonna make it look like our brand
gives heart attacks but we're going to
make it look like your show isn't real
let's have some fun we're [ __ ]
talking about it on our podcast right
now yes this is none of that
second of this show i have a little bit
this is pretty [ __ ] fun
i laughed i laughed out loud you brought
this up you're like yeah we should check
this out and i was like alright is a
story that big i kind of felt like i was
like really is it that big and i came
home and i see my girl on the couch
she's kind of crying a little bit
what's wrong what happened she was like
who's the big guy oh get that [ __ ] out
outta here
[Applause]